[Music]
I don't care oh [ __ ]
open that door my brothers nothing bad
happens it is him saying there you go
there you go
just when you thought it was safe if
you're under 18 hang up right now
[ __ ] if you're under 18 get the
[ __ ] off this thing [ __ ] go do
your homework you little [ __ ]
bulletproof vest ready oh [ __ ] we're
burning down this [ __ ] tonight
what the [ __ ] is everybody went to
church churches all the [ __ ] now it's
the real Church I'm gonna give you the
real body you're [ __ ] Christ ear it is
you little [ __ ] the Jew killers
here Kevin gasps woman is on his way
we can't smoke around Kevin [ __ ] little
sadhus boxes with a telescope from
across the street they probably got
[ __ ] somebody over there with no
names no names
[Music]
well there you go you bad [ __ ]
you feel there's gonna be an easy night
[ __ ] no Nelly
and guess who's back with him oh [ __ ]
[Music]
BAM
TKO the roof this [ __ ] hits
harder then [ __ ] Conor McGregor's
left this [ __ ] so get ready to go
we got the [ __ ] container from Japan
with look at this [ __ ] here this is a
pill Emile right there this is this is
it this is with Jeff choice for today
this is Jeff Sessions is [ __ ] bad
about this is [ __ ] apples are we
this is Japanese people that's a date
before they eat [ __ ] sushi is [ __ ]
are you ready to go Lee away
[Music]
cuz you're all I got come at you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here reporting
live to you on a Sunday night
I got the last and what killed [ __ ]
Susan Richard Pryor smoke when he lit
himself on fire we're gonna fill this up
to the tip-top Magoo does it Sophia I'm
saying just like that we don't have a
museum here this ain't no reform use ium
you ain't gonna come here and see how
this is nothing nothing lasts here it
all goes down even our earthquake supply
we had is dwindling
don'twe but alas no questions
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the smoke is going into my
eyebrows I love it you're I'm saying
I'll rub them on the plane the [ __ ]
smoke will come on it's Sunday [ __ ]
let's do this [ __ ]
it's another ho-hum night eating that
dick plan you're gonna watch 60 minutes
that you [ __ ] boring family and
make-believe you're interested who gives
a [ __ ] here we go you're all I got
tonight boggling at the Bundys we don't
give a [ __ ] be on the Lord's Day who
gives a [ __ ] one lung is better than two
I'm saying who's talking to anyone I'm
talking to the people here minded
business in we went deep last week
tonight so just a light night I only got
like nine wait watching points I can't
be ending up at the coral cafe [ __ ]
mumbled and stumbling like last week but
as usual go back just a little fuel
injection here leaves already panic and
[ __ ] him sober all things calmly siren
let's see how many [ __ ] edibles gonna
eat over there nah he's ready thank you
man I'll eat the whole [ __ ] thing eat
the wrapper I don't give a [ __ ] this is
the [ __ ] rig right here this is this was
Moses [ __ ] ate when he parted the Red
Sea it's in the Bible
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this tonight
that's why they're so good these things
they got them sealed up see you can't
can't break into it
[Music]
here we go you can't listen I'm gonna be
nice nephew if it's there today I'll get
in there you know saying I know it's
[ __ ] the Lord's Day strap on your
seatbelts people you wanna rock and roll
you want to be keeping a [ __ ] oh I'm
type of dude let's get this party
started Sunday night on to the skies
away with some other guy burning a
little [ __ ] thing here you gotta get
to hit already y'all get the bond ready
for Lee I'm gonna give him some [ __ ] in
this shitty likes
[Music]
but look on your face
highest [ __ ] you think I smoke a bong it
since last night who gives a [ __ ] which
spots a gun what do you want to be let's
go suck that mule maybe it is
there you go leave no [ __ ] around not
I don't leave with it I'll burn that
finger down there you go that's the one
that's the one you guys thought you
having a rough night looking uncle Joey
showed up I'm saying what else you gonna
do with your time I got [ __ ] toenail
clippings in there i buffed out my big
fun night toenail
I sprinkled it in there we got some good
weed in there Doug
[Music]
don't worry you throw that one smoking
right now it's a fungi weed I put some
mushroom busting a everything
listen it's Sunday night people if you
ain't gonna [ __ ] get down take a
uniform off and quit go hang out at
Starbucks or Michael dose with your
friends here on the church we throw down
you understand me
we don't [ __ ] around it's [ __ ] Sunday
whatever happened last week happened
last week it's a whole new week do a
bong it right your gulf do you 22
pushups and tell them all to suck your
dick understand
you got [ __ ] tribal Coahoma juice on
tap anyway it don't matter people we're
all gonna end up in the same [ __ ]
hole anyway you might as well going that
hole laughing they're [ __ ] crying
right or wrong what do you want to cry
in for the whole let's laughing for the
[ __ ] hole you walk up to heaven you
[ __ ] laughing everybody else is sad I
left my cattle gives a [ __ ] you're up
here now with the wings I'm hanging out
with decent people anyway what do I got
there that date Nyack Wednesday nice old
down so if you're thinking to come and
go
there's no stand up list okay [ __ ]
Santa Ana Casino in Albuquerque you got
Thursday night if you can't do Thursday
know what to tell you and it's better
anyway 7:30 home early
nobody knows nothing you give mom a
stabbing the car the wheel and then you
got Columbus [ __ ] the funny bone on
April 28 which is 423 animal see for me
420 is every [ __ ] day I don't need no
crib top [ __ ] thing to tell me when
the [ __ ] get refund you understand me
I got a handle on that just goes bang I
start hearing Chinese people yelling
it's time to smoke some reefer Jack the
[ __ ] needs some beef jerky and whatever
the [ __ ] you got once I hear some
Chinese people yelling Bing it's time to
hit that [ __ ] pipe a debt understand
me call me what you want I don't give a
[ __ ] I mind my business
I stick to my P's and Q's I do my little
show when I go home and I'm saying take
that camera and shove it up your ass I
got 19 weight watcher points left [ __ ]
and the weigh-ins tomorrow's the 6
o'clock [ __ ] with me anyway what's
the problem anyway Kevin gasps woman's
on his way all you got to do is wait and
sit tight
it's youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz is the
place to be you little filthy [ __ ]
animals I love you I'm gonna feel bomb
it's myself but you know what what the
[ __ ] if you hear you quit we might as
well do one more for the road how the
respectful let it's again again this
dammit
if you ain't gonna party would let her
Sunday don't come out
stay with your [ __ ] family go to the
beach and whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do here the church mentality we get down
or you get didn't get my muscle I bring
the higher why oh [ __ ] we think should
we do one more
what's up the [ __ ] Joey would you bother
me for I was just about to give my wife
the stamp that's why I'm gonna do one
[ __ ] water respect for you guys for
being family for being savage I'm with
you you're with me and they want to be
with us always remember that [ __ ]
[Music]
it's a whole new week let's celebrate
for a whole new [ __ ] week if you were
doing [ __ ] opium last week [ __ ]
this week you used to meet popcorn
you're back [ __ ] you follow me
[Music]
that's it and that's that whoo
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz if you
want some of this Russian weed you gotta
go to the Sun Center go tell them uncle
Joey sensei you wanna see the devil
[ __ ] jumping rope you follow me
two nights ago I saw the devil jumping
rope usually a double jumping rope no
it's not a pretty sight so anyway I love
you [ __ ] youtube.com give me
seven minutes we'll get this party
started
stay black